how I started hello everybody
yeah hello how can I not do this without
his Crips every little thing you think
that's me every little thing you think
that me every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'd
be fine without it
[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua fields Millburn
and I am solo once again today but only
for this intro you'll be hearing from
Brian in just a few seconds here I think
you're going to love this episode I know
I certainly did it was our first time in
Vermont and the questions and the energy
were just truly outstanding and also you
know it was our first time doing a
hashtag ask the minimalists of battle on
stage it was it was sort of like a rap
battle but without any rapping going on
I think I think you'll see what I mean
later in this episode when you listen
along get to that lightning round
section of the podcast but first because
we didn't include an added value segment
at the end of this episode I wanted to
make sure that I still gave you some
added value this week so this week I'm
finding value in in a couple things
first off fellow Montanan john mayer has
a new album it's called the search for
everything what a great title let me
just say this it's definitely not my my
favorite John Mayer album but I'm
totally okay with that because it's
still a really really good album and
it's been the perfect soundtrack while
I've been on the road these last few
weeks it's a great mix of blues and rock
and pop and R&B all in one album so
check it out it's called the search for
everything wherever you you get your
music these days I listen
on on Apple music personally but I know
it's on Spotify and Google Play and
probably even on physical CD if those
things still exist which I assume they
do I've got a couple more albums to
recommend also a book to recommend as
well but I think I'm going to wait until
next week when I can talk to to Ryan
about those Ryan is in Tokyo right now
he's in a little vacation with his
partner and and so I definitely want to
spend the time with him talking about
some of these albums and a book in
particular so let's hold off till next
week to discuss those but I would like
to hear about you what are some of your
favorite albums so far this year you
know I love hearing about new music so
you can hit me up on Twitter I'm just at
a jsm now since if you remember back to
episode number 71 Ryan and I announced
that we were doing this little
experiment it's the no social media on
my phone experiment I don't check
Twitter every day now because I don't
have that app on my phone but I still
check it a few times a week right there
from my computer so it's always the best
way to reach out to me is still on
Twitter at jfm or you can reach out to
the minimalists as a whole word is at
the minimalists there and speaking of
that app les experiment it's a pretty
interesting word appleís it almost
sounds like a 40-inch slip or you know I
don't know what it is but this whole
appleís experiment I hope to once Ryan
gets back I hope to chat with him about
how that experiments going with him I
know I've learned a lot in the last
month or so and I'm looking forward to
hearing what Ryan has learned as well
alright so that's really what's adding
value to my life right now let's move on
real quick to right here right now this
is where we get to talk about what's
going on in the lives of the minimalists
we're working on some pretty exciting
stuff right now and actually you know
you can help us out with some of those
exciting things so three things that are
going on right now first this year 2017
we are working on building a new audio
recording and film studio how awesome is
that I mean talking about expanding out
to new vehicles and new media and just
improving what we're doing overall this
is one of the things that we're really
focused on
the thing that we're really excited
about and because we refuse to clutter
our podcasts with advertisements we need
your help that's all we created a
patreon page over at patreon.com slash
the minimalists what is patreon you
might ask good question
patreon is it's a website that allows
people who create stuff like the
minimalist podcast for example it allows
us to build our own subscription service
and allows our listeners to contribute
on a per episode basis now why would you
want to contribute to the minimalist via
patreon you ask also a good question
until now the only way to support the
minimalists was via paypal donations
which honestly those have been great but
patreon will actually help us improve
our podcasts as you know we don't make
any money from advertisements because
let's face it most advertisements suck
can you imagine if if we had to start
shilling for some underwear or mattress
company
oh yeah I I can tell you this and it it
wouldn't feel good I wouldn't feel good
about I know Ryan wouldn't feel good
about it either and that doesn't mean
we're knocking anyone else who does ads
it's just frankly it's not for us plus
being ad free allows us to to do that
added value segment each week without
any bias toward a sponsor and that means
that we can recommend something right
and whenever we do recommend something
it's because we truly get value from and
not because not because someone's lining
our pockets and so because we refuse to
do advertisements we are turning down
literally tens of thousands of dollars
I mean seriously it is an insane number
every single month and I'll just be
honest it's that's totally fine with us
because it aligns with our values but it
means that we need your help so we can
do some cool new stuff with our podcast
so if you go over to patreon calm the
minimalists there's also a link to that
in the show notes you'll notice that
there are a couple objectives what
patreon calls goals but for those of you
who know me know I don't like goals but
there
objectives on our patreon page first off
the first one is just called studio when
we reach 2,000 patrons we will have
enough money to build a new audio
recording studio which will allow us to
take live callers on the air it will
improve our overall audio quality and
it'll also allow us to bring on
occasional guests to the show we'll have
people on from time to time it will also
help us pay our producer podcast Sean
who's smiling right now and because he
has a wife and three kids so if you want
to help out podcast Sean earn a full
time living wage then you certainly can
Plus will also have the flexibility to
test new types of Episode two
experimental episodes shorter episodes
longer episodes more episodes while
continuing to focus on our our normal
high quality standards and number two
the second objective over there on our
patreon page you'll notice it's just
called video and this is honestly the
one we're the most excited about when we
reach 5000 patrons patreon patrons say
that's a lot of times that Sean when we
reach 5,000 patrons that which honestly
that sounds like a lot but it's actually
less than 1% of our listeners when we
reach 5,000 we will have enough money to
build a film studio and hire a full-time
filmmaker to help us create a video
version of the podcast and in this film
studio will be more than just the film
for the podcast it will also allow us to
create other meaningful videos webseries
television shows interviews
documentaries video essays live streams
and much more and by the way if there's
any additional revenue from patreon so
say we we build the studio we're paying
Sean we're paying a filmmaker we're
doing the filming that we want to do and
if there's any extra money where does
that go - does it make its way to my
pockets into Ryan's bank account nope
that's not what we're trying to do here
it's not going to go to our individual
bank accounts at all it's going to be
donated to donated the charity actually
and so just to be clear we are not on
patreon
just so that Joshua and Ryan can make
more money that's not what we're
interested in we do we do just fine on
our own
but we want to incorporate some
interesting new things into our platform
and those interesting things require
money and that's where you come in would
you be willing to be part of the 1% we
want you to be part of the 1% and what I
mean by that is the 1% of our audience
who helps us create something meaningful
and helps keep our podcasts 100%
advertisement free if so head on over to
patreon comm slash the minimalists and
become a patron today you can contribute
any amount you want and if you
contribute two dollars or more per
podcast episode you will have access to
an exclusive monthly live stream where
you'll be able to ask questions and
interact with the minimalists and you
can even watch the video after it airs
which is especially nice if you if you
miss that live broadcast and it's only
our patreon supporters who will have
access to this exclusive monthly live
stream thanks for helping us create
something meaningful y'all we appreciate
it
all right back to right here right now
item number two second Ryan and I are
always looking for creative ways to
contribute to the world around us we
build an elementary school in 2015 we
help the 52 victims of that horrible
pulse nightclub shooting in Orlando last
year and just last month we donated a
majority of the profits from our first
four lessons now tour stops to help
build an orphanage on the us-mexico
border and now here's a new way for you
to help contribute to charity and it
won't cost you a penny
throughout 2017 Ryan and I are going to
donate ten dollars to charity in your
name for every iTunes review we receive
this month it means we're starting the
month with twenty three hundred and
thirty reviews on iTunes so every review
on top of that means ten dollars goes to
charity and the charity we've chosen
this month is one of my favorite
charities it's called the against
malaria foundation which according to
give wall org the against malaria
foundation is currently the most
effective
life saving nonprofit in the world what
do they do with the against malaria
foundation let me ask you this did you
know that malaria is one of the leading
killers of children in Africa in fact
malaria has killed more than half the
people who have ever lived on earth just
think about that for a second
more than half the people who have ever
lived have died from malaria and so the
against malaria foundation provides
insecticide-treated Nets that save lives
the foundation estimates that it takes
thirty five hundred dollars to save one
life so for every iTunes review of the
minimalist podcast this month Ryan and I
will donate ten dollars which means that
together we will save one life for every
350 reviews this month and really this
serves two purposes number one we all
together get to contribute to a
meaningful calls and by the way that
costs you nothing it's going to come out
of my pockets and Ryan's pockets
individually and number two those
reviews on iTunes they actually help our
message reach more ears it goes into
their algorithm and more people hear
about our podcast so it's really a
win-win for everyone
we obviously prefer a five-star rating
if you find value in this podcast
because five stars is the most helpful
way to spread our message but we will
still donate ten dollars if your review
isn't five stars of course we always
want it to be genuine we don't want to
co horse you into giving a better rating
than what you think we deserve but if
you find value in the podcast we would
love five stars so just give me a quick
favor right now pause this podcast and
leave a quick review on iTunes and we
will donate ten dollars in your name
this month even if you don't listen
directly through iTunes
say you listen on Spotify or SoundCloud
or YouTube or overcast or somewhere else
iTunes is still the best place where the
reviews are the most helpful so if you
head over to iTunes it's just iTunes
comm slash the minimalists or if it's on
your little podcast app and leave us a
review we'd really appreciate it and
we'll be able to help some folks out
together by the way I got this idea from
from a friend of mine his name is Lewis
Howes he was a really great guy and he
run
a great podcast called the school of
greatness so Thank You Louis I think
you're going to help us contribute to a
lot of folks this month and hopefully
we'll get to save some lives in the
process and one last thing for right
here right now it's item number three
Ryan and I are hitting the road once
again next week we're bringing the
lessons now tour to Spokane Seattle and
Portland and then we're headed to Grand
Rapids Chicago
Madison Minneapolis San Diego Los
Angeles Indianapolis Cincinnati Columbus
Cleveland and like 20 other cities each
night during the lessons now tour we
give an in-depth talk about minimalism
followed by a live podcast and a Q&A
session and of course a whole bunch of
totally optional free hugs after the
event you can find your city and get
tickets over at les is now calm some of
those cities are pretty close to selling
out and so we won't be adding second
shows in any of those cities I know
sometimes people will say well we're
going to add a second show at 10:00 p.m.
or something
I'd say Ron and I give it our all during
those shows and we are beat especially
after doing an hour or so of hug line
after after the event so there there
won't be any second show so get those
tickets while you can
speaking of sold-out shows I know some
of you have received a sold-out message
in Los Angeles it looks like that event
may have been sold out but they may have
opened up some extra seats there are
still some great seats available in Los
Angeles so get them while you can LA it
is going to be a killer night and you
know what there's going to be a very
special secret guest there that night
there's going to be some serious and a
few cities throughout this tour I'm
really looking forward to this Los
Angeles stop hope to see you there
all right that's a long but necessary
intro just to recap number one support
this podcast at patreon.com slash the
minimalists so we can create a small
film studio and create meaningful videos
about minimalism number two leave us a
review on iTunes and we will donate $10
in your name and number three
come see us live les is now calm and now
enjoy the show Ryan and I had a blast in
Vermont and we hope you love it as much
as we did you can stay tuned after the
show for some comments and
tips from our listeners hello everybody
my name is Joshua fields Milburn's and I
am Ryan Nicodemus and together we are
the minimalist welcome to the minimalist
podcast we discuss what it means to live
a meaningful life with less we are here
live in Burlington Vermont all night
this is going to be good you know what
so we we as the minimalists have been to
48 different states and we've been to
all the contiguous United States except
one Vermont and we are here today and
thank you for walking much we really
appreciate it
alright so we've got some we got some
questions here we've got some folks
lined up usually what we do is we take
calls but it'd be weird if you just like
put your phone out and you called us so
we have a microphone right here so we'll
get started go and give us your name and
tell us what your question is and we
have we have a few answers up here you
brought the answers I got on don't worry
I thanks guy throw the answers my name
is max I'm from Philadelphia nice
actually Saratoga Springs but my
question was you said you lived in a
three-bedroom apartment and after you
got rid of 80% of your stuff how did you
feel this how did you how did you kill
the space but knocking - it got knocking
- into a deeper sadness I'd let someone
else fill the space for me I got rid of
the place
I rented it out I mean at that point
when I was sitting there faced with 80%
of my stuff still in boxes I was just
like looking at it and really what went
through my mind was why he was like tens
of thousands of dollars worth of stuff
that I've purchased and then I started
to think about like the narrative that
I've told myself and how my life was
going to unfold and I always told myself
you know I'm gonna get everything I want
I'm going to find that happiness and as
soon as I as soon as I'm happy I can
start doing the things that I actually
want to do like you know maybe I could
retire at age you know 40 or 50 and you
know have a decade or two or three of
living out the rest of my life I wanted
to
and as I was kind of having that thought
I was like wait a minute like if I
didn't have if I hadn't spent tens of
thousands of dollars on all this stuff
if I didn't have this huge mortgage I
wouldn't have to work these 60 70 80
hour work weeks and I could actually go
do the things I wanted to do now I could
go see my mom who lived a half hour away
I hardly ever saw her
I mean maybe seven or eight times a year
major holidays and her birthday Mother's
Day things like that the major holidays
that were important to her but I got to
tell you every time I showed up to a
family event they would always like make
me feel like what I was doing was okay
because I'm the only person in my family
to have a college degree and the only
one who kind of climbed the corporate
ladder like that and every time I went
to a family function they're like
there's our corporate success you know
good job Ryan but but it didn't feel
right so for me that's that's why
minimalism really captured my attention
it was because if I started to live more
deliberately and make better decisions
with the resources that I had I could
start doing the things I wanted so one
of the first things I did well the very
first thing I did was got rid of my
brand-new car and I got that for those
who've seen the documentary the tour bus
that we have the 2004 Toyota Corolla I
went and got that because it had no car
payment on it it's kind of set deck and
everything yeah it's only loaded I still
have that card leaks when it rains but I
love it every time it rains on my head
I'm like this is so much better than a
car payment but uh but yeah then the
next thing was was getting rid of my
home so um I actually rented it out
because I couldn't sell it because I was
so upside down on it I did get rid of it
I finally dumped it off eventually but
but yeah for me minimalism it was
it was going to help me take take back
control of my finances and that was
really the first so my stuff and then I
really sort of focused on my finances
and when I sold a lot of that stuff
which I spent tens of thousands of
dollars on and I lost tens of thousands
of dollars because you know you can't
tell for what you what you paid for it
yeah I was able to start paying down
debt and live a much more meaningful
life
I remember after Ryan's packing party
all this stuff was still packed up in in
his second living room which was
actually sort of the there was this four
year was house was so nice it was a four
yay but it was you walked through the
Fourier and into his second living room
yet all these boxes and you walk beyond
that and that the house sounded
different and I'm like so this is the
sound of minimalism because the ia would
reverberate a bit more and you realize
that a lot of the stuff that we have we
did you see our documentary by chance I
did okay great so so for those you
haven't seen it's a documentary called
minimalism a documentary about the
important things and this guy holding
the camera right here is the guy who's
responsible for it's not the Avella
ladies and gentlemen he is a extremely
talented director and we're grateful
that he was able to take several
thousand hours of our nonsense and put
it into a coherent narrative but anyway
with the documentary we interviewed a
minimalist architect as in was Frank and
he said a few things that really stood
out to me but one of the things he said
is when he built a house for someone he
doesn't ask them do you want a living
room do you want it to car garage do you
want a dining room do you want this do
you want this do you want walk-in
closets because everyone says yes
because we feel like if the architects
asking this us this of course we're
supposed to say yes it's what we're
supposed to do instead of asking them do
they want these things he has the people
one question how do you live your life
he says I try to build houses around
people's lives
instead of trying to force them to cram
their lives into my house that I built
for them and to me that was so
applicable but of course most of us
don't have the luxury of well I'm going
to build a house around my life
necessarily if you do I think it's great
in tiny homes are really ideal for that
for the folks who are who are interested
in that I really admired that it
wouldn't work for me in my family right
now I have a partner and we have a
three-year-old should be for next month
and I can only imagine living in the
hundred and twenty square feet with her
it was she's like a hurricane and so it
wouldn't work but my point is that what
I learned from this is okay I can take
that same principle though and I can
find a space that is more ideal for the
life I want to live and then on top of
that even if it's not the most ideal
space I've learned to become a lot more
comfortable with silence and part of
that is visual or material silence as
well you don't have to fill an empty
room to make you more complete you you
are already complete thank you thanks
for the question thank you
did you drive from Philly okay okay hi
my name is Ann and welcome to Vermont
first thanks man thank you beautiful
state by the way oh my I can't well you
picked a good day this is so we live in
Missoula Montana which i think is like
just one of the most beautiful places in
the country if you haven't been in
western Montana go like find a way to
get there at some point um and if you
can take a road trip there even better
because there's so much to see on the
way there but Burlington makes me feel
like Missoula makes me feel I can tell I
can tell you this so we the first time
we went to Missoula was five years ago
we were at the end of our very first
book tour so it was like 2011 and 2012
and we were really lucky if six people
showed up at an event but it was great
because it was it was kind of a
listening tour and it shaped in many
ways it shaped the material that we
wrote in our book everything that remain
and then what we talked about in the
documentary to help us understand what
really resonated with people let us
listen to people a lot more and that's
why we do a lot of this podcast we were
able to to get questions for people but
when we were driving through Missoula it
was one of those days where it was like
you picked the right day it was it was
Missoula with summer and I had never
been to Montana we just finished a tour
we were really tired we finished in
Vancouver British Columbia we're driving
back to Dayton Ohio and all along the
tour we were looking for the next place
to go to write this book our second book
the memoir everything that remains and
and as we left Vancouver we fell asleep
in in Idaho Coeur d'Alene Idaho and we
woke up there and was just gorgeous and
then we drove into Montana and it was
like cliche beautiful I I'd have to use
like stock phrases from like eats poems
or something in order to describe
Montana accurately but we were driving
down the highway and I first saw my life
have ever done a triple take that it's
along i-90 and it's like the most
perfect day it's 80 degrees and sunny I
look over and there are four college
kids skinny-dipping from a waterfall on
the side of the highway and I [ __ ] you
not
there was a bold eagle that flew
overhead now I'm from Dayton Ohio I've
never seen a bald eagle in my life the
only thing they could have been like
more Americana was if it had a flag in
its talons anyway thank you for walking
us here please did you answer question
not I hope I asked your question I'm
kidding I'm kidding I know um well I
guess since I've been following you for
the last three or four years it's the
middle of some middle list has the right
label has it's kind of nicely I feel
like you know I'm sixty so when I was in
my 20s I felt like people around me
thought I might have been cheap I
thought maybe in my fort and I didn't
feel right and I thought May
in my 40s it's I was frugal and I didn't
feel right either so this feels better
but it's still not quite right so I was
saying if you could change the label but
not the genre like what would you call
it not minimalist cuz people like my
friends go what we not gonna have
anything or house we not gonna buy
anything you know that kind of stuff and
I was like no I things but when I do
it's intentional and it's you know
quality and etc sure I like what would
you call you I can't we tried to buy the
simpletons calm but it was already taken
I think they would have gone in a
completely different direction okay I'm
sure that's a parody website of us I can
tell you that there are a few directions
you can really go with it there's a
great book called essentialism by Greg
McEwan yeah I mean so so essentialism is
a term that is this all-encompassing as
well to me it means some of the similar
things to to minimalism I think I think
minimalism can be more broad because it
also applies to architecture and art and
what I found is with minimalism it's
really like the bones are the are the
beauty of the thing I really enjoy
minimalist architecture we run a side
project called minimalism life are any
of you familiar with it at all a couple
of you solve your hands yeah yeah so if
it's a fix if it's just minimalism life
on Instagram we're just minimalism dot
life and you can you can see the side
project there but we post a lot of
different photos of minimalist
architecture and what I really like
about that is yeah it is rather stark
and almost aggressively stark at times
but it can be gorgeous because it really
gets down to it the essence of the thing
and that's what minimalism is about for
me but as a lifestyle it's not about
deprivation and so you can go back and
look at the aesthetics who believe that
pain and suffering was the key to not
having pain in a way which seems a bit
quixotic to me to think that that well
I'm going to suffer so much that I won't
suffer or you can go back to the Stoics
I mean I don't think stoicism is the
right word either but there's a lot of
wisdom
Epictetus or Seneca or marcus aurelius
and any was ancient 2000 year old wisdom
that pulls forward to today or you can
look at people like Emerson and Thoreau
and some of the stuff they did but that
was also a little bit about deprivation
and to me it is much more about getting
back down to the essential and I
realized that minimalism is probably the
best term it's the most ideal term and
the most imperfect term as well because
it piques people's interest in here
minimalism you're like okay that's
probably going to be radical and then
what Ryan's job and my job is is to show
you that it's not a radical lifestyle
it's a practical lifestyle but at first
when you just hear the label it sounds
radical and so maybe maybe essentialism
has a a softer edge I would have called
intentional ISM for you guys yeah yeah
but um and have you ever heard the
swedish term legume yes okay yeah we you
want to explain it though cuz you're
probably better job than me I just spent
three years in Stockholm Sweden which
they're kind of like that whole form and
function is very much the Lego means
just the right amount of stuff not too
much and not too little yeah okay thank
you yeah I don't one thing I would add
is you can pick whatever labels you want
you know I mean when I think about
labels the first thing I think of is
like you know wearing a t-shirt was the
label on it or something
I don't pick labels like that but you
know I know there's people out there who
will label themself a minimalist and
they label themselves you know a
Christian which is great you don't have
to just be a minimalist you can you
don't have to choose just one label I
guess what I'm trying to say yeah we'll
have people come to our events like we
we did an event in Jackson Mississippi
and we had this young couple come up to
us after I said it's great to see a
couple guys out here spreading Jesus's
message
and I just said a thanks yeah I'm glad
you think that and then and then the
next week we were in Seattle and and and
this woman the small woman came over she
goes I just love to see a couple guys
out here spreading these Buddhist
Maxim's yeah and I said thanks a month
later we got an email from someone who
said did you know that Muhammad was the
original minimalist I said thanks you
let me know that's great
and so I agree with Ryan I think labels
can be useful everything I mean this is
a speaker that is a label right I'm
sitting on a chair that is a label we
don't wanna give too much meaning to the
label though so I also agree that you
can pick whatever ISM works best for you
I think sometimes that that radical may
name helps us identify and put put a
name on a change that we want to make
but sometimes yeah I can't be too
aggressive and so you can call it
essentialism intentional ISM you can
just call it simple living you can call
it simplicity you can call whatever you
want how did okay I'll call it
self-actualization a process a life
process a studied feng shui for many
many years and practice it in my life
but the paperwork the the tedium of
going through like 40 years of
collecting papers on workshops I've
taken in workshops I've given and and my
life is a lot about self actualization
and living an intentional life and
welcome to Vermont but I have a hard
time with the papers because there's so
many of them and I have to touch each
one and go through each one and it's on
some level it's really boring and long
and hard yeah what happening inspiration
or help about that boring is so for me I
I think decluttering is boring and I
know some of you will disagree with me
and I envy you because I think most of
us find decluttering boring is so Ryan
and I found a way to make it a little
bit
or fun so so Ryan you heard about his
packing party your ID he talked about
his packing party and we came up with
this idea called a scanning party if you
know I figured out if you put party at
the end of anything Ryan showed up I'll
bring the beer we're currently on a tour
party have it a blast and no and so we
strongly recommend with paper-work with
photos you you have you buy a relatively
inexpensive scanner these days for those
of you were actually interested in you
can see the one that we use it's the
minimalists comm slash scanning and we
talked about the scanning party that
that we do in there in detail but
basically what we did is okay I didn't
want to tackle this by myself how can I
whenever I come across when these boring
or mundane tasks one of the first things
I'll ask is how do I make this more
interesting or or how can I get someone
else involved and you know how can I
pawn some of this work off on Ryan and
so you invite some some friends over and
have a scanning party is especially
helpful with with the photos because you
get this little scanner and it's not
like those old timey
scanners remember like back in the 90s
and early Oddie's where you'd have that
big fax machine slash printer slash
scanner you'd pull the top up and you
put one photo down and then 18 minutes
later you'd have an upside-down blurry
image on your computer though these
scanners are handheld they don't even
require the a wire anything you start
feeding photos through it and it scans
them relatively quickly and what I found
is by doing that process with the photos
and then with my paperwork as well I was
not I was not only able to get them out
of the boxes in my attic in my basement
and my clauses which they weren't doing
anything there but I could actually put
them in digital picture frames and then
people it's strange they they actually
want to look at it was right now someone
comes over to your house they're like
you know the first thing that they say
is not hey without your photo albums I'd
love to see that trip to Hawaii that you
just took no but there's a weird thing
happens when someone comes over and you
have a ditch
picture frame so when the first thing
that goes like we are just drawn to
glowing screens and and so people start
looking at these photographs and and
what I realized is that I made a real
experience out of it because we would
pull the photos out and we sit down we
talk about and we'd say oh that's the
time you went there or what is what's in
this photo and who's this and you right
I was actually surprised by how many
photos I have of people I didn't know
who the hell they were I have no idea
this is I had a whole box of photos I
had no clue who these people were I
don't know if I got it from Goodwill or
something but but anyway and then from
there it bled over into the document and
then it was quite the task at first it
was a long weekend but once that weekend
was over and then you just keep up with
it on a weekly or monthly basis it
becomes so much easier and you realize
the easiest way to keep that paper
clutter out is to address it immediately
whether it's a receipt or it is a piece
of paper or it is a photograph and the
nice thing about the digital picture
frames too is you can upload them
whenever right from your phone even now
if you take a picture from here you can
upload you I'm not telling you to upload
a picture of us to your district right
well I'm saying is it would be possible
if you took a picture of your feet right
now you could upload it immediately to
your digital picture frame and you can
actually use these things you weren't
using before it's funny you bring up
function because I don't really know a
whole lot about function way from what I
understand is the way things are
positioned in your home make you feel a
certain way that's kind of I know goes
much deeper than that but I didn't
really have any opinion on that until I
got rid of everything will 80% of myself
and in in my in my home I remember like
sitting down after getting rid of
everything and I'd you know flip up my
laptop to do some work and it was so
peaceful like I remember being able to
concentrate more to focus more and I
didn't realize how every little thing I
had in my home was just catching my eye
in the periphery and totally distracting
me from being able to
focus so yeah that's IIIi need to look
more into that um the other thing I
would say too is you're right like going
through all that paper that work it is
hard and you know unfortunately a lot of
the times we confuse simple with easy
but simple is not easy it is it is very
difficult it takes a lot of willpower
takes a lot of discipline it takes a lot
of work so I would just kind of echo
what Josh said I would encourage you to
go through that paperwork and you know I
was thinking while Josh was talking
about the scanning party another thing
we came up with with too was is the
30-day men's game have you ever heard of
30-day minimalism game so the way it
works is you find a friend or family
member who also wants to declutter and
get get rid of some things in their home
and you both agree to start on the first
day of any month you can pick any any
month you want um one month is this
where are we okay no so you know and May
first is coming up pretty quickly and
you both agree to get rid of one thing
on the first day of the month and then
on the second day get rid of two things
another third day three things and on
the floor you got it so forth and so on
so you just you know you bet something
real easy like someone cooks dinner for
the other person who ever you know
doesn't make it to the end of the month
or more $10,000 but you know what if
both of you make it to the end of the
month though you both win because you
would have gotten rid of like 500 items
so you could do that with your paperwork
um it you know maybe you don't tackle
all the items in your home but just
start counting out pieces of paper
every single day and just take it a
small chunk at a time it's really easy
in the beginning like you know one thing
to think then you get to day 20 and
you're like oh man I got here with 20
pieces and then tomorrow 21 and then 22
like in the last I think five days of
the month is when you get rid of Lake
you know the other 30%
of the stuff that you have left to get
rid of but just taking in small chunks
and yeah it is going to be some hard
work but the more you can kind of find
ways to make it fun and interesting it's
definitely going to go a little bit
easier
thanks Alex question thank you making it
fun is really important thank you for
making this fun oh thank you yeah we
really appreciate that thank you about
it hi so I'm really big fans of you guys
you guys have been so inspirational to
me fortunate my name is Michelle I drove
two hours from Hudson Falls New York and
I actually grew up in Saratoga so who
ever was from Saratoga hey so and I and
I listen your podcast every week and
it's funny because as the caller's call
I go alright they're going to say the
minimalist game or they're going to say
changes people with those you can change
those people alright so I'm having fun
listening that's verbatim so what I
drove here for is I know your back story
so well and I heard you say something
interesting tonight which leads to why
I'm here so you said that getting rid of
things and decluttering is really just
it's not the reason right the reason is
after so what I don't know about you
guys which I want to know is what is
your life look like now so you have
freedom and you do a lot of things I
know some things but you know what are
your what are your day-to-day life look
like that you're able to have so much
freedom like you still go to work
somewhere or is that gone now because
you don't have to what's that look like
yeah I think my life is is considerably
different from even when I first became
a minimalism that was the interesting
thing that appealed to me when I first
found out about the minimalism and the
people that Ryan thought about whether
was it was Colin right and he was a you
know world traveler but I didn't want to
be a peripatetic writer I don't even
like traveling that much the kind of
three things I hate is traveling public
speaking in large crowds of people
it's not that I actually hate it but I'm
just I'm an introvert and so I get
uncomfortable um and so but I find that
when I put myself in that discomfort
zone that's the place from which I grow
the most but so when I was 28 and I
first embraced minimalism and I'm 35 now
my life went from this 100 miles an hour
to slowing down to essentially zero and
then I did pick back up and I live a
considerably different life and I have a
partner we have a three-year-old she'll
be before really soon and and you know I
live in a completely different state I
have a different career I make money a
different way too I teach a writing
class and so that that is how I can make
an income but it's something that is
congruent with the person that I wanted
to become and so now what I really look
for is do my daily actions do they align
with with my values and back back then
back when I was 27 I didn't even know
what my values were right and so I
probably would have given you some
decent answer but I wouldn't have meant
anything would have been a sort of empty
veneer that that would have sounded semi
coherent and and what I've learned is
that yeah maybe that veneer is important
but also what's inside is far more
important and so I've been able to
uncover what my values are and then work
toward that and now today you know I
aspire to be my my 40 year old self and
and that's the the person I'm looking up
to right now and I'm constantly I'm
constantly failing at that by the way
and I think it's that's important to
recognize you Ryan and I don't sit up
here with all the answers or or even
most of them what what we figured out is
a way to have a bunch of little failures
on our way to to a type of success that
is is beyond happiness because I don't
think I don't think happiness is the
point I think that was what that was
actually the problem
for me I was just chasing happiness and
and I kept chasing it and I didn't
realize that happiness was actually a
byproduct of living a more meaningful
life and and that's really what my life
looks like now you know I don't think my
life is that much different than anyone
elses because we do have an office in
Missoula um we got to get internet
somewhere because we we run a blog um
but you know for me I I gave my
priorities when I was you know 26 27 28
years old I gave my priorities a lot of
lip service if you ask me what my
priorities were then like oh my health I
got to be healthy without your health
well then you're you're not gonna be
happy and I gotta have good
relationships in my life and you know
you got to work on that big passion
project and really want to contribute
more so forth and so on but really I
just gave that stuff lip service and
when I was having that revelation moment
with 80% of myself still sitting in the
boxes that is when like I said my
perspective had changed when I was like
wow like my priorities are this well
here's what I'm focused on and when I
realize is that our priority priorities
are not what we say they are our
priorities or what we do and that is
where I really started to focus and
that's where I focus today um I wish I
had some like sexy answer for you about
what my day-to-day life is but I'll tell
you three things I focus on every single
day I will meditate and sometimes just
60 like my goal is 60 seconds and
sometimes it turns into 15 minutes
sometimes it turns into a half hour it's
great and other times for 60 seconds I'm
like I can't wait till this is over
[Laughter]
the other thing is I will try to do some
type of exercise whether it's walking or
going to the gym you know do you know
three sets of squats and some three sets
of push-ups or you know just something
to just to focus on my health I hate
going to bed thinking like wow I kind of
ate like crap today and I didn't even
like go for a walk the third thing I do
is I will I will ask myself every day
how or what have I done
to add value to the people in my life so
whether it's Josh or whether it's my
partner Mariah or if it's my mom or
whoever maybe I'm always trying to make
sure that I'm adding value to to the
people who are closest to me and then
you know I feel my day with other stuff
like I love a snowboard I love to hike
we live in Montana so you know if you
can get get outside of your apartment
then there's endless possibilities to do
which is really hard by the way because
like I mountain-bike a snowboard and I
really want to start fly-fishing but
like I know if I pick that habit up that
like how much stuff is going to come
with that and it's not again let's not
wrong with having stuff as long as it's
adding value and and I'm using it but I
know that I already have a hard enough
time finding the time to snowboard in
the mountain bike like I'm not willing
to bring any more hobbies into my life
right now but yeah I mean I think now to
echo what Josh said I focus on living a
meaningful life and for me what that
means is my short term actions aligning
with my long term that I use and beliefs
thank you thank you for coming
thanks man howdy Luke hi my name is
Amanda and I live in Burlington Vermont
and I had a hard time making it to this
portion of the evening because I had
such a strong urge to jump out of my
chair go home and start pulling stuff
well thanks for making it through
so I work in market research and one
thing we really like to do is segment
the market into the low-hanging fruit
who are easy to convince and the hard to
reach customers who are hard to convince
so I'm curious and all the experience
you've had talking to successful
minimalists and talking to people
struggling to just get started what are
the you know beliefs or values or what
makes it you know harder for some people
to do this versus easier and kind of
what messages or what you've learned
helps people get over some of those
struggles getting started and to get you
started thinking about that one
observation I've had is that I know a
lot more men than women who seem to be
better at keeping their life pared down
so it's wondering if there's gender
thing going on and then another thing is
in Vermont
some of us label ourselves as
environmentalists and we don't like to
waste things so if there's any kind of
anti waste thing that makes it hard for
people but and any other ideas she
totally cheated with like three
questions well played yeah well I think
it's interesting because we're living in
an interesting time and I don't think
the idea of minimalism is new like
intentional living Ryan and I didn't
come up with this concept right but I
know I told you that at first man but um
II know I I think that that we're it's
an old idea like an old wisdom but we're
facing a new problem and that is
unchecked consumerism at a level that
the world has has never seen and it's
because of a lot of different types of
marketing where you you segment customer
groups and you figure out the most
effective way to to
to partition them and sort of divide and
conquer right and and it's even more
pernicious now with the online world
because the segmenting is formulaic
there are algorithms so if you're on
Instagram for example and by the way I'm
not saying any like the internet is evil
or Instagram is evil I'm not saying that
I'm saying these are tools but sometimes
some of the tactics used in the
background can be punished as' so
Instagram is a good example because they
will sometimes run certain algorithms on
you as a user you will be user 419 in
experiment 1617 B and they're going to
figure out how many likes they need to
give you over the course so say a
hundred friends of yours like your
picture right hold all 30 of those for a
minute and then wait until a minute and
barrage you with those 30 because you
know they know there will be a certain
level what they're trying to figure out
what that threshold is for you so how
many likes money to give you within a
60-second time frames that you get that
dopamine rush and I could hook you up to
to a brain wave machine and I could I
could check to see where your cortisol
levels are right and I can figure out oh
it was that twenty-ninth like in 60
seconds that raised your cortisol level
to this to this level and now and now
you're more susceptible to this ad from
tide and so that is sort of the the the
problem that we're facing now is there
are really well-paid engineers and
demographers who whose full-time gig it
is to aggregate your eyeballs on on to
their their widget or your product or
service basically and and so I think as
as humans what we have to do is we have
to start to develop the mechanisms to be
able to to handle that and man it's not
easy because it it's almost like we're
fighting
we're fighting again
the the impulse Ryan and I just recorded
a podcast episode that'll be out next
week actually in the middle of it like
just on a whim I said I'm going to
delete all the social media apps from my
phone this is an experiment and so I did
and Ryan's like oh that sounds neat
I'll do it - and you did it right in the
middle of the podcast and and so I think
sometimes what the answer is is
experimenting going a little bit extreme
in one direction it takes the pendulum
swinging from here to here to actually
end up eventually and then that
comfortable middle but once we end up
there that targets going to change too
so we have to we have to constantly keep
reevaluating yeah I don't speaking to
your question about men versus women and
being a minimalist I have seen problems
on both sides I mean you know one
woman's hoard of makeup might be another
man's hoard of sentimental items so I
really don't see a huge difference and
there are plenty of women minimalists
out there I don't know if you've ever
been to Kourtney Carver's website but
it's be more with less calm but she's
got like a great like if you're if you
or anyone out there are having some
troubles like with clothes for example
she's got this great project it's called
Project 333 and basically you choose
certain pieces of clothing it's like 33
items of clothing there's a couple like
caveats like I think like maybe jewelry
doesn't count there's a couple good
totally counts man it sounds jewelry
yeah but there is there something that
doesn't count though underwear yeah
underwear but real minimalist don't wear
underwear you share a pair of underwear
like Josh and I do
but my point is is that you can usually
tell who is who is doing this project
because they're usually really well
dressed because when you have to choose
just um I say a few but 33 is a lot of
pieces of clothing what saying the guy
who wears black t-shirt and jeans every
day um but but when you when you're
forced to make those choices then you
are forced to pick the best-looking
pieces of clothing that you have so I
don't think there is a huge difference I
think maybe different problems and there
has to be some different approaches
between men and women but I don't think
that it's easier for men than it is
women or vice-versa and the
environmental thing this has been on my
mind for the last two years two and a
half years so one of the beautiful
things about minimalism is that when you
consume less while you waste lasts so I
mean you know having a less of an impact
on the environment is a beautiful
byproduct of being a minimalist I would
not consider myself an environmentalist
because I I'll forget my water bottle
and then I'm like super thirsty and I'm
like oh crap like all I can get is like
plastic I'll recycle the plastic bottle
afterwards but still like twin geing and
like buying a plastic bottle but I would
love to talk to Josh and I would love to
talk about that more here and maybe get
some ideas but here's the the kind of
the problem I have with writing about
the about the environment is I can't
think of anything that isn't almost kind
of like fear-mongering because like
right now I see an environmentalist or
um you know an article on how we're all
you know doomed essentially it is all
doom and gloom stuff like there is no
the only benefit is is like hey your
grandkids will live which is great like
I care about my grandkids but a lot of
people don't give a crap about theirs
like yeah what I will it will let our
grandkids figure it out so the trouble I
have when writing
out the environment is how do I make
someone who could you could care less
about the environment how do I make them
find the joy and caring about the
environment because when you talk to
someone about keep recycling for example
like that took a lot of people it sound
like a miserable task like I got to
separate all of my you know metal from
plastic and so forth and so on I had
someone give me a really good idea about
how kids love to pretty much help with
anything you ask them to do so I think
it would be really easy to get a child
on board you know kind of help have them
help you with recycling or whatever it
may be in teaching kids young but how
how do you make a 25 year old you know
kid who 25 year old kid that you know
old I am who you know like maybe they
they're just you know kind of being a
bachelor and ordering pizza burrito or
whatever like how do you convince that
person without the doom and gloom talk
to be an environmentalist so if you have
any ideas tweet me because actually you
know it's what I Josh talked about us
deleting our apps off our phone so the
whole thing is like what that forces me
to do is I have to choose the times when
I'm going to go to Facebook on my
computer and check all those
notifications and over the last like
three days being on the road like it is
it has been stressing me out so much
like I'm gonna get and check those 200
freaking notifications that I get every
single day I took I just got rid of my
facebook yesterday like I totally
deleted it all together thank you very
much
I wasn't looking for an applause but by
the way if you follow the minimalists on
facebook that's not deleted yeah and by
the way jessica is around here somewhere
jessica williams runs our social media
accounts I heard high up there ladies
and gentlemen Jessica Williams
so if you're sending into great pictures
or we're on Instagram while doing like
Instagram stories we always try to I
mean the question I always ask and I ask
Jessica as well before we share anything
is is this going to add value because I
mean the the noise ratio on social media
now is so high in it I mean it's you
know it's like it feels like an
infomercial sometimes when you you you
get on to social media and you just see
ads and this barrage of sort of of you
don't have an ad blocker on your
Facebook I don't need to think but all
exist does it really yeah yeah that is
great well I'll finish that with a story
about the gender the gender thing so
we're in Pittsburgh last night and one
of the first couples that came out to us
they were they said something about well
the you could clear that the wife had
dragged her husband there that night
right and so it was almost the opposite
of your question because she was like
how can I get him on board with this
minimalism thing and I'm like well the
way to do it is not to drag him there
kicking and screaming right it's really
to show to show the benefits of it and I
think it is less clear with the
environmental thing because it's not as
a media with the nice thing about
minimalism is yes that is a saw the the
less waste
I mean considerably less waste in my
life now I mean I I probably produced
more waste in a year than I do in a
decade now back in my 20s right just
because it's not that I I didn't care
it's I didn't even know that I should
care or why I should care or what might
you know what's my motivation
but then toward the end of the night we
had we had someone come up and ask about
um well it was it was a guy he's like
I'm really trying hard to explain this
to my girlfriend like she just doesn't
get it and so I think I think we all
struggle with and so one of the things
that Ryan I've been talking about very
recently is how do we how do we find a
way not to just communicate this message
like we have tonight but but how do we
find a way to help other people
communicate that message more
effectively to the
our friends and family and loved ones
not in a way that beat them over the
head with it but how do we get them to
to help put it out there in a way that
inspires others to to move forward with
less thanks for your question excellent
all right before we move on to this
lightning round for anyone who's
listening to this at home we'd love to
hear what you have to say so if you have
a a comment or or a tip for anyone who
asked us a question today you can leave
with some voicemail at four zero six two
one nine seven eight three nine we will
air our favorite comments and tips on
the next episode also we have a you can
send a voice memo now right from your
phone so you can just record that on
your phone send it to podcast at the
minimalists comm and you know what time
it is Ryan oh yeah it's time for our
hashtag ask the minimalist lightning
round indeed I'm speaking of social
media we're on Twitter and Instagram at
the minimalist and facebook.com slash
the minimalist and during this lightning
round this is where we basically try to
give you a bunch of pithy answers to to
your to your questions so you're welcome
to to come on up now and ask a question
and we'll do our best to answer it and a
hundred and forty characters or less if
we don't have a pity thing for you then
we'll just maunder on a bit until we
figure something out all right we can
edit it later howdy hi I'm Alex I'm from
where New Hampshire I thanks for coming
in Allen I follow you guys thanks rose
Paula cast or whatever awesome and watch
crash sorry um you come up close to
Megan in there so my question was um can
minimalism be transferred for not just
like your house but like for other
aspects of life like school or
relationships oh yes yeah so so can can
minimalism bleed over into other areas
of your life of its I got something busy
oh go for it unless you want to keep
going no please save me um minimalism is
not just a well
home minimalism is a well curated life
oh that was good well thank you look
well this is like this is like our
version of a rap battle how about that
do you get away living that we can get
pity or here intentionality is
contagious
are you one that bark one up Shawn
we have other up there so you have to be
named Shawn and be from Ohio to be on
the team but other Shawn is talented
editor-in-chief at our publishing house
which is called asymmetrical Press
let's give him a round of applause he's
a really talented novelist by the way
Shawn mihalick is his name and writing
novels with his game hello my name is
Maya and I was wondering when you guys
tell people that you're a minimalist
what's the difference in their reactions
six years ago to now oh okay I got to
fit the answer Oh
I mean I don't think I'm give the
applause out of this but this is true
oh you set the bar low I don't care what
people think about me hmm
that's a great answer here we go here we
go what I don't care what people think
about me
I care what I think about me
you're welcome for that jumpstart hi I'm
Billy I'm from right here in Burlington
area thanks for coming thanks for coming
um so you spend 30 years collecting
stuff wanting stuff and then you stop is
there anything in the last half a decade
that tripped you up where it wasn't for
value or purpose you were just like I
got to have it and then you were like oh
I didn't need that if I died with no
regrets
I'd really regret that the best parts of
me are made up of some of my worst
failures that was good no good man mind
god oh what what what what are the
judges oh that was you for sure
mentality you cannot go all right oh oh
can you tie it up howdy would today hi
I'm Sammy hey Sammy
I'm wondering if you've had to teach
yourself to say no to things I say no to
as many things as I can so I can say yes
for the important things
good answer yeah I can't beat that one
yeah all right
tiebreaker here we go hi guys i'm tyler
nsv thank for coming so this might
mirror a longer answer depending on how
you see it so uh would you say that your
how would you say that your message has
been received by people in poverty who
need materials as a necessity to move
forward in life therefore can't see
there is a reduction necessarily yeah
I'll give you a pity but we can expound
on it
the awesome it doesn't matter how much
money you have if you make shitty
decisions you're probably going to have
to shave your life maybe I should have
not said shitty we got to just bleep
that out on the podcast I know I said
[ __ ] at least once tonight right no all
right money doesn't buy happiness but
neither does poverty and so that's my
pity answer to you but but the truth is
yeah I wouldn't wish my childhood on on
anyone honestly I mean it was like I
know a lot of people look back to their
their their childhood days with all and
like nostalgia and like I just don't
want to remember it at all it was it was
really really bad
I in in the talk I really downplay how
shitty it was honestly and and I can
tell you that when when I did go out and
got I got that corporate job and like
started making money it was more
comfortable at first and and when I
thought we were unhappy because we
didn't have a lot of money growing up
now that actually wasn't why we were
unhappy we were unhappy because of the
poor decisions that were made on a
continual basis we're all going to make
poor decisions and sometimes a lot bad
luck and that will compound for
or but what I learned throughout my 20s
I started making good money and then
better money and even better money is
that just allow me to make even worse
decisions I had more resources to make
bad decisions and the contentment had a
lot more to do with the decisions I was
making on a daily basis the habits I had
the actions I took daily I was in the
corporate world at my at the peak I was
making about $200,000 a year in Dayton
Ohio and when I walked away from there I
made twenty three thousand dollars a
year and not only was I happier but
again happiness isn't the point but I
was more financially secure making
twenty three thousand dollars a year and
that's because I was making much better
decision I was less comfortable but I
was living a better life
thanks for the question yeah thank you
thank you good luck with everything
thank you that's a little bit high for
me we got two more here we'll be extra
pithy
howdy what's your name hey mister hi um
I was wondering how do you deal with
people giving you gifts you don't want
and you don't need because surely you
don't want them and you don't need them
I got it I got it
presence is the best present you son of
a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
um I'm trying to figure out a way to
make this pity but I'm for the sake of
time I'm just going to I'm going to go
over 140 characters uh you can't you
deleted your Facebook account so I got
Twitter I know right I'm going to do
like multiple tweet you did tweet stream
all I did it later now if someone buys
you a gift they want you to be happy
right if your life is happier without
that thing in it you'd be doing them a
disservice if you didn't get rid of it
hmm
oh good disqualified though alright we
saved the best for last pressure
hi my name is Morgan I've actually never
heard of you guys my friend brought me
here tonight I'm really into it though I
like it also um I heard you say that you
have a child and I don't have kids but I
have a lot of people in my life that do
have children and what I've seen over
the past like since like 2010 to now is
kind of kids get stuff they get a lot of
stuff whether you want them to or not
they just accumulate small toys and I
kind of want to know I don't I guess I
don't know if you have children I do not
but I can get some really good advice on
kids I'm and I'm into it without having
kids I got all the advice and I well I
guess what my question is like having a
child how do you deal with the idea of
minimalism and you know the realities of
having a kid you know there's a lot of
like tiny things that come with kids
yeah yeah for sure I got a pit the
answer but I don't play - I'm totally
stealing please do we're tied three to
three right now - go for it I would say
uh having children makes minimalism even
more important Oh
[Laughter]
again then I camera he is getting on our
camera I totally agree with that I'll
try to expand on if I don't have I'm not
gonna have a shorter answer this better
than that um so here's what I've learned
so I'll give you a stat so the average
child in the United States has 238 toys
they play with 12 daily and and they
forget about the other 226 still math
podcast right you tell with double check
so you're supposed to be the human
advocate we know I I've learned that our
kids are watching right actually
everyone's watching I can tell Ella what
to do until I'm blue in the face and
she'll listen to a certain extent but
only if my actions align with that I
mean the simplest examples will be a
dinner I'm like and you've got to use
your fork stop taking that rice up with
your hand you know you're a big girl now
right we talked about big girls do not
put rice in their hand and shove it in
their mouth and and then of course you
know eight minutes later I'll she'll
catch me pulling something off her mom's
plate Josh you're supposed to use your
fork I'm like oh and like okay where's
she getting it from she get it from me
like I'm setting the example and that's
actually the good news it's good news
for several reasons first is because I
can set a good example but second it
makes me raise my own standards for
myself right it helps me be more
congruent and then I think that starts
to bleed over in other areas of life too
and so I think if we want to teach our
kids about living a meaningful life with
fewer but better things we have to show
them what that means not just tell them
what it means it's important to tell
them to use you know the vocabulary and
develop the vocabulary as a family
together so you can talk about it in
educated way but more important to
develop those habits together and now L
is at a point where she always wants to
donate everything because we we have a
donation box up front and so she
constantly is just like
when she's done play with the toy she
takes it overboard she'll get it to line
play with it for an hour say I want to
donate it now or we'll be eating dinner
so I want to donate this kale and I try
to explain to her doesn't she get
donated to me usually I'll eat it but
but no i-i've realized that that those
behaviors that it becomes a pattern over
time and yeah it's not easy but it is
pretty simple thank you thank you that
was a good last question yeah so but
before we wrap it up I just want to
thank the venue eat we've this is our
eighth tour and seven years so we
started the web sites over six years ago
this is our seventh year and we have
done hundreds of tour stops over the
years and I have not been treated as
well by by a venue then we have here and
thank you all for just giving us such a
great welcome yeah amen
you can tell the team whether it's the
lighting or the audio or just the people
that cook does dinner here tonight they
are like a family and it's just it's so
refreshing to see that a place like this
exists you never know what you're going
to get when you show up you never know
really what to expect and I try to go in
it without any expectations but this
place clearly has very high standards so
we're just really grateful that you
allowed us into into your home here
tonight and I really want to thank all
I'm gonna take a couple other people too
Conrad's back there filming this we
don't know what we're going to do with
what we're filming right now and that's
so as I mentioned we started this thing
six years ago we just went out on the
road and sort of listening to people and
we would tell a story like I this is
going to kill and people are like
crickets like and and because we didn't
have anything really prepared but then
all of a sudden Ryan would just mention
in passing like the packing party and
they just move on to something else and
some of they wait what a minute what do
you what'd you say a packing party what
the hell of a packing party or when I
started talking about you know dealing
with my mom's stuff and then that became
a story which I was able to flesh out in
time and and that led to us writing
minimalism live a meaningful life and
then everything that remains in an essay
collection and we put this documentary
out and we've been able to reach so many
more people and now we're out here just
doing it again we're trying to listen to
more people so we can figure out where
do we go from here and we're getting a
ton of ideas from this so we're grateful
that you're showing up we're filming
some of it along the way in hopes that
we can we can create something new and
find new ways to to inspire other people
and so really the last person I want to
thank here is you we're just really
grateful you decided to be here tonight
and if you leave here actually before
you leave here we'll be in the back
dishing out free hugs and yeah they're
transferable to so you can pick one up
and take it with you and hand it off to
someone else you need six a day for
happiness twelve a day for growth the
cool thing is when you
when you get a hug you you also give a
hug and vice versa when you give a hug
you you get one and so you're welcome to
grab one there totally optional by the
way oh we we we don't all right go ahead
we did a criticism episode of our
podcast where he just read mean tweets
from people and someone said my favorite
part of the documentary is when that big
Greek guy hug rapes everyone What did he
say he's like every time he hands out a
hug take it drink and then die I promise
you all the hugs are consensual
no but if you don't want to hook that's
totally fine we back there with books as
well we'll sign some books if you if you
want to buy one if you don't want to
borrow it or you didn't bring a wallet
you couldn't afford one you want to just
pick one up you want take one home we'll
buy one for you so if you if you want a
book it's on us if you if you can't
afford it for sure yeah make sure after
you if you do get a book like after you
read it minimize it right like we're not
trying to like you know peddle books
like hey give it to a friend or family
member or like donate it to your library
so many libraries across the country
like have our books in their library
because of that reason so definitely
minimize it if you decide to get a book
yeah for sure I think once you read it
you realize that maybe I don't need to
keep holding on just put it on my
bookshelf next to everything else it's
always like the the sign of someone who
hasn't read the book early I've got all
three on my bookshelf uh-huh but yeah
we're just really grateful you decided
to come here with us we'll see in the
back and if you leave here with one
message we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works thanks for your time
[Applause]
funnily here are some voicemail comments
and tips from our listeners hi there
this is Meredith calling from Melbourne
Australia I just wanted to leave a
message for Jeff from Pittsburgh who was
talking about coping with grief and loss
and handling the possessions of loved
ones who's cast over and how that part
of the grieving and recovery process I
just wanted to call in because I lost my
beloved grandmother Nora two years ago
and we were so so close and when we were
organizing her home following her
passing there was a lot of stuff in
there that you know she had herself
hadn't really used for many years to be
honest and I was wanting to you know
carry on celebrating her life that just
didn't feel willing to take on all of
the stuff but the few items that I did
take with me and bring into my home or
our home that I share with my husband
were a couple of really practical items
so I kept Mama's Mixmaster Mama's soup
ladle and Mama's G tea cozies are there
three things I can just think of off the
top of my head actually very few other
items I did keep but those three things
are really practical things which mean
that when I'm using those things at home
and I use them in my my daily life while
I'm using them I'm talking to mama I'm
thinking about mama and these things add
value to my life in a really practical
way so rather than just being on a
mental or you know being the funny old
china you know girl with a bunch of
balloons that she had on her mantelpiece
these are things that she would use in
her own kitchen and I can carry on using
in my own kitchen and yeah so just that
just came to mind when I was listening
to you on the live broadcast and I was
just hoping that maybe that might might
be helpful to you to just keep the
things that that you can use and when
you do use them that you can start a bit
of a conversation with that loved one
and you know talk to them as if they
were here because
that certainly adds a lot of value to my
life we've mama whenever I'm I'm
thinking about her and missing her hey
guys Rebecca here from Colorado and
former five-year Missoula resident I was
just calling regarding your last podcast
called things specifically when you're
talking about scanning and scanning
parties and buying a scanner and whatnot
Ryan is right there's an app for that
and my favorite app for scanning is
called tiny scan it's a really awesome
app it's free for a limited number of
documents but if you have a lot of
documents you can upgrade to the pro
version for $4.99 so basically just take
a picture of your documents or photos
and you can save it as a color black and
white or a photo and it emails you the
file so it's really great and hopefully
some people will get some use out of it
hi guys this is Nicole from Omaha
Nebraska and I wanted to share how I
overcame my depression a few years ago
and one way that it really really offset
my depression was the book The Happiness
Project by Gretchen Rubin I read it
and it really really changed my
perspective on how to live a happier
life
and to throw away my depression um over
a matter of months her book just really
outlines ways to boost your happiness by
either decluttering or spending more
time with friends that you haven't seen
for a while and just basic everyday
points to just boost your happiness
another book that really helped was Eat
Pray Love she was a woman who completely
had her whole life turned around by a
simple act of leaving her husband and
just how she regained regained her
happiness little by little by just
diving into an adventure my very last
thing that I would say that helped me a
lot was having two separate journals
I had one journal that was all of my
happy thoughts that would go on
throughout my day even if it was very
very minimal happy thoughts and I had
another journal that was just my bad
thoughts and believe it or not when you
write down your bad thoughts and then
you read them aloud
it actually looks ridiculous and you
start wondering why you even have those
thoughts to begin with and I eventually
threw that journal away years and years
later but having that journal really
opened up my eyes to how minimal my
worries were
[Music]
every little singing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it every little thing
that you got a hand
every little singing that you guys you
gotta reach for and you gotta grab oh I
bet that you'll be fine without you so
tear your eyes
[Music]